mon place au banc test
[Musique]
le blind test arbitrée par monsieur à
philippe corti et ce soir on juil
j'ai fait le tour
oui
et
bright est anjou démons ce soir là vous
connaissez le principe du samedi soir
bonsoir turbine tirard dix ans de 2005
mais si c'est un truc de jeunes alors
ouais donc le principe est simple je
veux l'interprète et non pas le titre de
la chanson est pour vous aider sachez
que c'est soit consacrée à un ange soit
un démon c'est la lumière et les
ténèbres et la lumière et les ténèbres
exactement didier
de la salsa du démon
hahaha
n'a pas le temps mais loin
oh
m
non
hors cac jusqu'au niveau
l'iran voulait manger bio elles sont
bien bien alors déjà un point pour joue
par équipe avant que vous m'avez où les
démons marque un point
[Applaudissements]
là
oh
m
on sépare du haut nil et n'a jamais
dansé au rythme où vous êtes bien vrai
bien joué aller en boîte ou sélection
peur d'avoir du retard est allé tête dès
le début bien didier et numéro 3 le nom
d euros je vous aime je vous attends
accès de l'avant
sympathie pour le démon les rolling
stones bravo tv j'ai vu que ça ils
s'arrêtent ou web et c'est ça tu vois là
d'accord car tout peut le faire mais moi
je mettrais jamais dit des quatre
interprètes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et juin
rires mais bon je passe je passe très
bien
c'est bien pour eux c'est pour toi c'est
pire que tu veux ça veut dire que tout
passe quand il y en a quatre et s'est
décantée à des questions ouais merde en
toute sincérité je suis pas baigné edith
piaf et aux stones
ah bah oui mais bon rien dit le mec qui
pensent que c'est l'expression façon
dont le petit james un petit truc là
c'est juste moi vous jeudi
la liste bravo révélation d
mr
est ce qu'on peut avoir du gaz où ses
fans il à didier
[Applaudissements]
très belle chanson
le souffle pas
ouais
génial
avant je soupçonne accès à des jeux les
répéter je me soupçonne ne voulait le
fait de souffler c'est clair j'ai
confirmé km 5 km et super honnête c'est
vrai c'est vrai ce serait vraiment
honnête - ouais mais c'est bien ces
messieurs labaki trouvez moi j'ai répété
ce calibre mais j'ai tellement j'étais
combien rapids et on a tous si on le
compare didier 7
[Musique]
le souverain ou du diable ni du travail
d'une masse
si belle
l'udc est mort
quels animaux
on n'est pas dans les jeux
dieu bon vous avez bloqué invalidés
c'est lui
[Musique]
alors on m'a dit dans l'oreillette le
bambou la veille où est passé sur deux
vous bon vous l'avez trouvé tout de
suite ça on peut voler avec les armoires
et de celles qu'on peut voler c'est
parce que j'avais trouvé une attention
or vous connaissez bien ménager une
nation de l'agneau blind test grandeur
nature
la soirée m
maintenant c'est une soirée dj ce que je
vais donc certainement un set comme je
les ai pas photo didier ans japon
supertramp c'est dur
maintenant c'est une autre école
[Musique]
moi je n'ai pas trouvé ici on a trouvé
le
josh holloway
bourges était le nom
allez vous plaît cette chanson cette
chanson des bons côtés situe l'enjeu
mais c'est ça effectivement c'est une
aja deux bouts de bois alors maintenant
on arrive au super banco donc c'est
l'attention après vous parce que le
superbe on vous sent très injuste et
dire que celui qui trouve le super banco
même site même si celles qui se trouvent
ils ont gagné alors que j'étais tout
trouvée tuée par aimer la vie dégage
c'est comme la vie mais des failles a du
bon voilà des fois il ya du bon
heureusement cependant voilà donc celui
qui trouve le super banco roma cette
année si vous trouvez pas le super banco
c'est ce qu'ils ont gagné qui
continuaient à gagner voilà c'est très
simple fait vite et l'interprète
itron
non
bien entendu
nous créons
2 0
axel sait ce qu'il faut faire leurs
nattes et ce soir c'est zucchero je
n'avais autant dénoncer sinon j'aurais
moi aussi j'attends ça veut dire que le
super banco est annulée à cause de
souffle à la prochaine fois je fais
évacuer la salle je boitais abolie mais
je voulais faire je me posais voilà donc
on en reste au ccd arrêté en ce compris
me trouvais ça non
samoa
le zéro
oubliez enfin je voterai sa peine
bref des bois il est mal canal là est
nommé claude ne bougeait pas tu peux
lâcher ce village et je ici pourquoi
cette pression sur moi sont tous là solu
alors gens n'ont cessé youth cup est ce
qu est ce que quelqu'un que justin bce
ue si la personne donc on en reste
d'autres plans précédents
on applaudit les dix mots les messieurs
mais bien d'un silo blanc
et j'accueille pour arbitrer ce blind
test martiaux philibeaux bordélique
bon
et se connaît
si vous payez
je nettoie ce petit je ne sais quoi qui
fait que c'est alors qu'est ce qu'ils
gagnent ce soir
alors on fait la revanche pour faire
plaisir au capitaine de la seleçao le
brésil alors le brésil
ici vous l'avez vu avec les plumes et la
france ici à dakar d'accord georges-marc
vous êtes en relais dans l'équipe du
brésil dont vous connaissez le principe
du blind test je veux l'interprète pas
le titre de la chanson je veux
l'interprète
ce soir c'est un spécial anatomy voilà
donc il sera prêt que des parties du
corps
didier première chanson qui chantent
oui au bio qui chôment pas
comme on l'a bien compris vous avez un
secret c'est sa petite amie vous avez
compris je veux le nom du chanteur
allait ou de la chanteuse bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
vous n'aurez pas répondre c'est le
premier qui répond connaissance marque
voilà donc c'était etienne d'abandonner
ou là sur les points lamar tous très
bien chanson numéro 3 on souffle pas
m
merci
en vrai on ne souffle pas asser le
public peut répondre si les invités ne
trouve pas évidemment le public je te
réponds ça ronaldo oui enfin ronaldo
c'est très bien donc là ça fait donc
deux pour le brésil est un pour la
france
didier
ban
j'adore vous
du chocolat
[Musique]
les grands
h
les grandes oreilles
les brésiliens c'est qui ce texte et
bravo
séparés pour la basse et musique petit
avec des grandes z'oreilles big baxter
didier
oooh
et
jean ribul tomber dessus à greenway
didier
lauryn hill a forcément on est à combien
l'a24 c'est la france qui gagne plus de
budget
l'interprète
oui
[Applaudissements]
un petit bled harry tripoli attention
oui
marsa encore ça fait quand même cinq
pour la france et 2 pour le brésil bravo
30 minutes didier
[Musique]
alors là
on va faire je pense sandrine on à
romane bohringer on avoue on abattit kif
on va faire pour la dernière émission la
fin de l'année on va prendre toutes les
stars du blind test fait très très chaud
que vous vous êtes ford michel rocard
merci catherine michel rocard excellente
et bien on code
celle-là on peut l'avoir cherché tu
étais là il revient à la première noce
est très fort ça très très fort
et voilà maintenant l'avant-dernière
attention
[Musique]
m
salez
tournus
le score à seissan à peine pourtant à
donner une revanche au brésil le score
est de 8 pour la france c'est 2
[Applaudissements]
c'est l'école
c'est un trimestre maintenant il ya le
super banco dans un super banco c'est
lui qui trouve le super banco gagne tout
le cirque le même temps si c'est vous
évidemment vous ferez que regagné je
vous ai déjà gagné mais ils peuvent
emporter le match grâce au super banco
six mois c'est injuste mais la vie est
injuste
didier qui chantent
très grave là quand le souffle passe est
très grave et gentil
[Musique]
l'amour
[Applaudissements]
elle viserait fait je sens
m
c'est un groupe maintenant oui
c'est la france donc il encore de vie
tellement je suis désolé pour vous merci
ils sont bons ce blind test
[Musique]
alors le blind assez simple afrique
braouzec je vous le dis il faut me
donner le nom de l'interprète et non pas
le titre de la chanson d'accord alors on
va faire un petit exemple didier si tu
veux bien qu'elle incarne
[Musique]
d'un mot c'est bien voilà c'était dur
c'était très dur non alors en pleine
c'est la chanson s'appelle pomme et
c'est parce que le blind test est
consacré ce soir aux fruits ça peut vous
aider à chercher charmant 1 s'est
consacré aux fruits et pour arbitrer le
blind test j'appelle mention philippe
portier
[Musique]
l'équipe des amis comme moi
non
n'a pas dit le poète enfin si vous
perdez vous êtes obligé de mettre mon
costume deux manades aubanel la gaude
bana bana et donc chers ex-aequo ça sera
le jeu du homard donc pas laisser mon
chapeau non jamais qu'est ce qu'ils
gagnent les gens alors les autres nadia
d'adrar des poires pour eux oui les
dépens de paris des membres des poires
et des scoubidous encore très fort les
enchaînements encore teddy des premières
chansons l'intervalle
à tapas disent que
janice bell
il va gagner c'est pas sûr qu'ils
gagnent non c'est pas sûr qu'ils gagnent
pourquoi pourquoi moi jean-françois
enfin vous avez fait tellement
d'émissions sur la chanson et les
chansonneurs mais il est trop rapide
non c'est pas ça c'est qu'ils y
répondent avant qu'on entend de l'agencé
fars le principe c'est de reconnaître
aux premiers accords l'ailé
bah oui c'est un vide en quoi ça
n'arrivera à chaque fois j'étais forme à
sa wii est impoli françois robinet
on joue en équipe on va laisser le
contrôle et loire est bien d'accord bien
seule journée il a entendu ou jouer
l'équipe bien boby lapointe bravo boby
lapointe grands génies simon futin fait
que c'est un génie qu'est mort il est
mort
ruiné avant un saut virelles sa maison
dit alors c'est bien on dit que s'agit
ni après ah oui là j'aurais préféré
qu'en dit saint génies vivants
il a cassé l'ambiance calme merci votre
troisième chanson
[Musique]
bien
non
huit ans connu dans la noblesse
serge serge replay l'ip lait est inondé
par celle de sailly jean-françois 4 on
n'est pas sûr de savoir qui a répondu
c'est comme au stade de france et si un
contrôle vidéo replay terrible et
mesdames messieurs
je vais
la marque est à mon goût c'est normal en
même temps alors égalité 2-2 chanson
numéro 5 didier gaz et les abords
assiste ici
faut parler plus fort et là bas voir en
vo risquait d'handicaper votre équipe à
lisa je vous le dis mais c'est
effectivement serge et charlotte
gainsbourg dans lemon incest puisque
comme vous le remarquez il ya que des
fruits dans ce blind test chanson numéro
6 ce qu'on semble traîner
jean françois kahn
[Musique]
donc l'équipe des pommes il t'a 4 et
l'équipe des poires et à 2 cette vidéo
[Musique]
mais c'est bien sûr
non c'est bien madame ou des comédiens
jean et maroilles il a mené abbey road
ils ont joué la marseillaise et
politique pour un politique c'est vrai
que c'est un des meilleurs politique
indigne en politique ça ça fait du bien
au pcf voyez mais oui il est un des
meilleurs politique qui s'est trop vieux
ce que vous passez il faudrait prendre
des trucs à moi le mariage groseille
tout à l'heure y aller seul absent en
revanche c'est très très dur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les anr tout un mystère attention 9
didier
[Musique]
en du salvador
à vernon incroyable adamo comme c'est ce
qu'on va faire d'amour et 6 s et quitte
la musique je sais de cette chanson je
sais pas c'est un classique verdi non
bah voila c'est pour ça que je vous le
dis je vais vers 10 6 georgette plana
cavell enchanté ça au départ et c'est
vers 10 est tiré d'un opéra de verdi
rigoletto rigolard exact vous êtes mis
des poires oui c'est vrai mais elle a
fait ça dans le film de richard berry
que ça vous va cette 500c j'ai du mal à
beaune attendant c'est comme ça c'est un
métier à risque et 7,2 juste je voudrais
juste rappeler qu'à dire qu'à d'amour
vide et sinon
[Musique]
oui
et
[Musique]
oui
cécile de france a trouvé ces primes
serra spirit meretz effectivement
chanson à la prime s'est déjà vu quel
est le truc vieux bonzes et mépris c'est
bien là le suit comme un drame on a
trois ces trois là là là oui c'est vrai
dams et a marqué la rupture des
générations quand même c'est à dire que
l'amour avec toi c'est pas le nom ni le
royaume tout à l'heure tout à l'heure où
d'accord entre belge péter szabo michon
bien eu très dur call me trouver
[Musique]
stacking
je
[Musique]
effectivement score est de 8 à 3 il n'y
aura pas de super banco il n'y aura pas
de jeu du homard et non élus dont nous
allons tuer le homard non non non non
non je suis pas l'homme
c'est ben omar bien ben bravo à vous
donner c'est elle qui va montrer alors
ça c'était dans l'été le jeu c'est
effectivement là qu'ils sont c'est
maintenant blind qu'est-ce qui la
séquence finale de cette émission
et pour arbitrer le blind test
j'accueille majeure vers caen
m
[Musique]
je
non
m
la mesure phare miliband est donc
arbitrer le blind test qui ce soir est
un blind test spécial joujou didier
[Musique]
montoya si un soufflage illias perd
d'âge bien alors vous connaissez la
règle du jeu c'est pas compliqué donc ça
tourne autour des jouets des joujoux je
vous demande
l'interprète
le
la chanson magnifique chanson je joue à
la casse bravo vous êtes une bonne
avocate et en plus c'est bien le
pavillon de jeu les petits aucune
réponse qui lui bah oui ouais bah il
faut pas non non non à lire il parle
anglais
on continue
cette affaire
que se passe-t-il que se passe-t-il joue
le monde nouvelle fois toi que se
passe-t-il on continue
oui
michel bélot
alors kévin alors les voitures en deux
et les poupées en d'accord at his on
n'avait pas dit ça mais on comprend pas
toujours bien nous oui c'est vrai c'est
pas toujours ailleurs c'est vrai on
continue
l'interprète
il y a
alors maintenant ils vont le vin
évidemment les disques az c'était chez
europe 1 donc il connaît maintenant
malina tient maintenant mais guidé une
autre version de cette chanson
ça c'est dur c'est christina didier
chanson numéro 5
[Musique]
mariani
m
est-ce que ça mérite un petit replay
parce que ça se joue entre le vayer
mariani un replay qu'un petit replay
[Musique]
mariani
je sais chance en numéro 6
l'interprète cristaux
parce que génial c'est qui fait chier
pour les rêves mais il est plutôt bon 21
sept
paris
le chou-fleur le débat
d'abord c'est vrai que c'est là qu'ils
en pensent
[Applaudissements]
c'est marié tu es marié tu es marié deux
enfants sérieuse et il plaît à les trier
mardi pluies dans les films
le chauffeur
dames c'est vrai c'est vrai 2,5 à bâle
pour toi qu'est-ce qui s'est tenue le
truc là j'ai envie de passer hier jeu
c'est jean marie bigard des dames et
messieurs chanson numéro 8 didier
[Musique]
quand je les ai redit
jean marie bigard n'était donc ça fait 3
pour les fous paix et 5 pour les
voitures c'est bien je suis d'accord tu
es d'accord à bascule arbitre je suis
d'accord 3 sec 23/100 chanson numéro
deux c'est dur
face à lui
c'est cela
là
charlene a trouvé nos armes chez vous
c'est celui qui a fait le jerk à 10
carats morgane elle a raison puisque
c'est thierry hazard
quoi
et maintenant nous arrivons au super
banco alors ils vont vous allez voir à
quel point la vie est injuste c'est à
dire que maintenant celui qui gagne
l'équipe i came et super banco a gagné
le blind test même si les dernières la
première oui c'est l'injustice de
l'aviron but symboliser d'une façon
extraordinaire
le didier le super banco
ouais
non c'est pas facile c'est pas que ça
c'était vraiment pas facile bravo mais
jamais totalement bon voilà c'est pas
une nouvelle mais donc voilà donc c'est
sylvie joly et l'équipe des petites
voitures qui emporte tout merci à tous
bien au pinceau blind test
et pour arbitrer le blindage j'appelle
moi j'avais beau porter
et
monsieur philippe corti jamais des
arbitres et se blesse ça va ça va très
bien pour elle c'est le principe
j'entendais des morceaux est ce qu'on
veut c'est entendre le nom de
l'interprète est pas le titre du morceau
aujourd'hui ce qu'on fait on fait
blondasse les poupées contre les
palettes à maquillage il fait déborder
bien
bravant laurent baffie
[Applaudissements]
salut
ouais
certains
oh
dalia ou dahlia famille assise à
soufflage ya à la fois chez répéter
bêtement une connerie mais il ya
beaucoup du mail pour vous ah oui numéro
de portable surtout les jambes elle
votre numéro de portable c'est à dire 95
des viviers la ta rennes
[Applaudissements]
ce qui a mis des super raconte sylvia
bien entendu c'est tout le point 6 10
trucs pour être hyper concentré à c'est
que des blondes décolorées c'est jeanne
indices quant à didier
des noms
michel vial
le
france gall ne soit pas si bête bien
britney week-end il est bon mot
m
bien didier basdevant
[Applaudissements]
je reconnais je reconnais que c'est
pénible de jouer d'études la madrague à
la 3ème note bien il est génial et trop
stylées
vous avez le vis comme l'on dit ouais
à
un message sans ces noms après la mairie
toujours tu couches avec ma femme ou moi
oui mais ça rien à voir avec les quiz
elle me donne pas des quiz je ne crois
pas à ça pour toucher le rouge tel film
j'en reviens pas milliken monaco tandis
que les coloris bon allez
migaud modibo maïga sauget
[Applaudissements]
assurément non
hier il y avait du souffle âge là mais
qu'est ce que c'est fou ce souffle h&m
soufflage la doc a atterri
non non
le
m
n'oubliez pas messieurs cheveux trouvés
geri halliwell on passe attention ce
soir c'est très important
il ya banco est superbe on ne dit pas le
nom je dis maintenant et avant tout est
super banco donc ceux qui trouvent le
banc cogan et ceux qui après trouvé sur
le cargo regarde mais c'est le juste
avant c'est encore plus injuste que
d'habitude jamie du ballet
antalya
loris baz
avi
je fais
je donne un indice comme julia elle a
épousé un vieillard
qu'est-ce qui a répondu ça me vient bien
vu
au menu une star ce soir ces deux fronts
ça fait deux fois plus tard
félicitations
donc maintenant mesdames et messieurs le
super-banco va départager les deux
équipes le score est de 6 pour les
poupées et de 3 pour les régates des
paillotes
voilà donc super banco didier
non
bordeaux
à
le
une thèse mesdames messieurs une cantine
ces militants
[Musique]
minimes il
il a une
c'était
attention attention ce soir à ge de
marcia souffle asia va très bien en
suisse est habilité spéciale gens de
petite taille en hommage à jamel est
maintenant qu'ils préparent le blind
test je comprends pas pourquoi c'est en
hommage à moi mais didier vous êtes
prêts
alors on est bien d'accord pascal sevran
spécialistes passer si on va passer
d'une ce que vous aimez c'est des nains
on va passer on m'appelle ses collègues
de real passait très bien
lucienne delyle très bien lucienne boyer
très bien trouve à la didier
[Musique]
niang années a reconnu princeton hp
ribéry le père et framboise jusqu'idi
guillaume olivier bailly sort trois
films par an même temps que jamais alors
chanson numéro 2
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
oui
tu fait croquer la pomme elle pense qu'à
ça et aller alors tout le monde veut que
justin interviews et tout je pense que
bientôt je vous interviewez parlant elle
est très petit elton john le blind test
en rapport avec les gens petit et en
hommage à jamel debbouze et à ma femme
d'accord allez petit la femme arrive
très petit mais les plus grandes
personnes son petit succès les parisiens
attaquent elizabeth taylor 1 m 58 alain
giresse km 56 bien sûr elle calcule
justement ça dommage qu'on veut séoul
c'est pour montrer que les faits sont
des génériques et là je fais ainsi
didier
il maintient
[Applaudissements]
monsieur norman a commencé la chanson
que l'on touche laliberté paris se met
en colère
une très jolie chanson très jolie
chanson évidemment cet effet pour pascal
sevran
ça va pas manquer didier
parce que non
m
thalia gemalto lien pourrait vous
éloignez talia d'un lien c'est parti
tout seul s'est rapproché d'un tricheur
ben arfa est à chaque fois vous soufflez
vous enlever un vêtement ralalala
données normalement oui on fait un lien
voix nathalie à chaque fois vous trichez
gendarmes et mangez pas ça va le faire
bien sûr les gens amusez vous et là on
continue
gallet
pitié je voudrais que la jeune fille que
la relève son pull-over je vous demande
de vous arrêter là heureusement qui est
la fois vers man les vermelles 5 et les
rouges alors là qu'est ce qui se passe
maintenant je ne comptais pas assis à
leur vision sa fille comme 1.651 on sait
quand elle souffre alors oui 2.2.2 pas
parce qu'il se passe justement il n'y a
pas eu barry white une fois depuis tout
à l'heure il n'y a pas eu son pote barry
white connaît et jackson aussi c'est un
couple aimerait bien être y sont sur la
cassette exact bien on continue didier 7
[Applaudissements]
6 à 2 bravo bio ah non non non non les
cavalières elle a soufflé mais il a dit
avant
c'est pas dégueulasse katia l'habitude
de crier tout le tard voire fallait sur
le nom d'abord attendant on fait un
petit replay serge un petit replay s'il
vous plaît
[Musique]
non
elle a crié allah par catherine barma me
dis que c'est un street veillant sur les
serge khalfon me dis que c'est julia
channel j'ai dit non à la lgv ayant je
pense que j'ai bien vous avez une vue à
la première mais le mot michel jonasz
sortie j'enlève l'oreillette parce
qu'ils se disent plutôt régis voilà oui
tout ne s'achète pas s'il vous plaît
j'avais alors je disais je pense qu'il
ya eu tricherie
le cabinet intervient qu'alien le
tablier fallu le talent y est allée à
l'italien le tablier si tout le monde
nous a dû
vie patricia attention c'est beaucoup
plus compliqué didier
je fais la gueule non
[Musique]
du petit david ellis mais je vous en
prie ch
on écoute monsieur l'académicien s'il
vous plaît j'ai pas compris un mot mais
une équipe à laquelle j'appartiens ne
peut pas perdre
mais on continue je jetais lui a donné
jones
les
en même temps c'est normal vous d'être
vous défendez la grande chanson
française pascal sevran et vous défendez
chantal goya foutent de ma gueule et
chaste à bourg ckoi par hasard il
s'évade accord est mieux et mathieu demy
défier et sammy davis junior et je peux
vous en faire d'autres et qui c'est qui
les a trouvés c'est bien cela c'est moi
qui gagne le plus c'est vrai c'est vrai
ce et d'équipements j'ai mis trois
jouent pas j'ai pas du tout le temps
mais je tiens incroyable non plus pas ma
faute à temps djamel avec thibodeau ces
valeurs je cherche et des cas des notes
janet jackson de ligue 1 j'adore charles
aznavour je connais la moitié de ses
chansons la poète un poète s'est redit
j'avais 20 ans
eh bien tu veux mais là j'habite seul
avec son frère c'est pour ces pauvres
gens restaient bien alors on continue ce
siège
à l'événement je suis désolé de dire
c'était drame du genre vous êtes ne
l'autorisent
par une équipe formidable parce que
sevran veillon des cannes et madame
nicole reagan c'est vrai dans l'équipe
gagnante président d'honneur ya que toi
qui joues yapi jours
bonjour des jeux vidéo
mais on continue il fait un mètre 85
c'est tout
voilà on m'a critiqué l'autre
non énorme donc c'est vrai que ma fille
on peut penser qu'ils connais bien ma
femme voir qu'il ya plus si affinités
mais vous non donc j'ai passé voilà moi
je sais grâce à arthur merci arthur donc
bravo ça c'est très fort d'avoir trouvé
dans ce gala légale mais non mais la
première note
j'ai chanté sur france galles pendant
que j'étais môme je jouais du piano de
peau et pour moi ça veut dire ça veut
dire qu'il était libre
par le passé nous et les soldats dans
l'état shan ou simplement la société ils
veulent être aimés
ah bon
auquel viennent chez moi et dimanche
midi ouais
ouais à dimanche midi vous venez à 12h05
sur france 2 sera bien oui
ce qui s'est passé dexia et j'allais
j'allais arrêter la musique c'est
extraordinaire j'allais arrêter la
musique pour écouter jean d'ormesson
mais vraiment la première note vous
l'avez reconnu voulu dire quoi jean mais
jouez vous demandez à vous si vous
pouviez faire quelque chose quand tu
ailles à la fourrure avec vous bon
maintenant mauvaise nouvelle très
mauvaise nouvelle parce que maintenant
bon c'est vrai que les les verts ils en
sont à 12 et des rouges ils en sont à 2
mais maintenant il ya le super banco et
le super banco
cela nous a permis à moi cela super
héros super banco serre que celui qui
trouve le super banco il a gagné c'est
injuste mais bien sûr vous le savez la
vie est un témoin de la place il est
capable de trouver alors le super bon
coup je le dis tout de suite c'est très
très dur on peut vous éloignez non non
non non vous vous éloignez excusez moi
je vous demande vraiment alia de vous
éloigner un peu j'ai pas envie de l'or
vous écarter un dieu j'ai pas une
finition à poil non plus donc vous c'est
pas le genre de l'émission n'ont pas lu
toujours bien alors attention
non mais je sais elle veut tricher elle
me sucer gelateria attention talia voilà
attention c'est très important c'est
comme une finale de coupe du monde de
football
attention vous êtes prêts didier
[Musique]
c'est vrai
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les sortes évidemment l'adaptation de
siemens candle in the family par les
soeurs qui étaient de jeunes malgaches
qui était très petit aussitôt dire la
mettez les soeurs vidéo comme ça les
servir jésus tu sais pas mais pour
trouver la réponse soit les villes à
avoir connu falabracs on peut connaître
mozart sans avoir 60 ans ouais mission
c'est comme mozart n'est ce pas ap une
banale et fallait fixer ce panier
bien sûr vous êtes un peu mauvais
perdant l'année de la table moi je dis
ça pour répondre à celle de pascal
sevran mesdames et messieurs donc raison
de plus
et chanter la vie demain pour françois
entre et maintenant par the blind check
sa jeunesse sera préparé par différents
ce soir j'accueille kate
non
le principe reste le même que tu qu'il
est opaque et killer je veux le nom de
l'interprète vous êtes prêt joey starr
didier
harcèlement attention je veux
l'interprète vous êtes prêt arditi je
veux l'interprète 4 killer aux platines
numéro un
[Musique]
nous aimons
pas
dimanche à 9 heures
waco
[Musique]
j'adore ça
attention parfait numéro 2
oui
mariage
joey starr pring blue jays longtemps
ma
chimère
ça allait
[Musique]
ap
oui
ragot ouais le catcheur numéro 3
[Applaudissements]
nbc
ses fidèles alors misons sur le bar
[Musique]
non je n'ai ni en bois quand j'étais le
10 juillet à phoenix qui c'est lui qui
s'est fait charles non mais billy paul
[Musique]
les gars
et
[Musique]
très bien merci numéro 4
le prix soeur
[Musique]
merci que sans ce n'est tous en poussant
tous mes collègues
[Musique]
m
avec 2
la dèche les gens
[Musique]
c'est un poids pour cette équipe et
quatre mois mais cela fait bien 20 ans
passés chez répondrait il est passé la
banco c'est chacun pour sa gueule
attention au cut killer
[Musique]
c'est
mieux elle sait bien
je sors
gvt style
[Applaudissements]
on perce un trou mais attention
maintenant celui ou celle qui va trouver
le méga banco on va gagner le blind
thèse attention cut killer qui comme
leur nom
ces stores point mort
[Musique]
voilà donc c'est joey starr qui est le
grand vainqueur de ce blind test spécial
quelques leaders basso blind test
[Applaudissements]
et aux platines j'accueille i did jacky
[Musique]
ça vous connaissez le principe je veux
l'interprète évidemment un ne me dites
pas le titre de la chanson ça sert à
rien dans un premier temps en joue par
équipe l'équipe de laurent baffie contre
l'équipe d' alexandre brasseur voilà et
puis après ça sera le chacun pour sa
gueule tu es prêt jack est ok attention
première chanson
[Musique]
c'était will smith qui l'a dit c'est toi
je pense la première mois laurent dumas
non si c'est toi c'est ta carte
attention c'est bon ça non n'aura pas je
pense qu'il vaut mieux pas savoir 1 il a
donné la semaine dernière
attention jaqee oui
[Applaudissements]
qu'avec deux points pour l'équipe d'
alexandre brasseur zéro point pour
l'équipe de laurent baffie
il le mérite attention jaqee ah là là là
là en même temps à la cei à voir serge
un petit
[Musique]
oh
ca brive
[Musique]
catherine barma qui est l'autorité
suprême dans cette émission dit barbara
[Applaudissements]
donc ça fait 3 points pour l'équipe
alexandre brasseur une gagneuse à la
bien venue de karim ça marche
allons-y jaqee
[Musique]
devenez
non
les mener vers 10 heures ce mardi
l'adedy a alors le combat l'annoncé de
leur premier en confiance ce rejet bon
ben ça fait un point pour l'équipe de
quatre points pour l'équipe d'alexandre
s'il avait la confiance aux gens voilà
ah non mais j'avais dit avant ça c'est
sûr là encore attention
jacky
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui mais alors james howlett à paris je
crois que c'est le 3 juillet donc faut y
aller voilà c'est tout parce que mon
avis c'est la dernière fois qu'on le
voit si je continue whissell avait
attendu avec sa mère fois oui à toi à
dia qui continue
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il
bravo ni dont ares b absolue la jante
enfin sister sledge we are family
oui à sa mêlée parfait bravo alors on
continue
jha qui accueille non
non
ok
ce pc
g
[Musique]
ch
jackson five bravo laurent attention
jack
[Musique]
attention jake lee
wen tong
ben je vais pas lui
[Musique]
bravo laurent donc ça fait quatre
pointures montrent bien laurent juge dit
lambert excuse moi roger excuse-moi
françois mais il était otage
il a trouvé dit que quand on se fait ch
et là bas 79 jours heidi krieger
alors allons-y jaqee
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça
[Applaudissements]
m
un drôle et toi tu m'as fait parce que
je sais que tu le sais mais elle a été
forte la petite halle a atterri à la 10e
bon ben ça fait 6 laurent été battu à
mort non n'a pas gagné encore jaqee
[Musique]
the reflex du rhône durance bravo
laurent baffie vraiment excellent et
maintenant on continue
jacky
[Applaudissements]
ouais
[Musique]
billy paul bravo on continue jaqee
d'autres
ces décès
le point bas là
[Applaudissements]
voilà si vous souffrez là le point bas
la cime je vais là-bas voila voila c'est
tout tant pis pour toi ce que la vie est
injuste soit là parce que la vie est
très injuste
allons-y jack qui voulaient du français
pour eux
[Musique]
alors bon
[Applaudissements]
oh oui
eh oui
warhol aux rita mitsouko and dit
attention jha qui font la culbute mer
[Musique]
sortie avec monique
parfait attention jaqee wifi
we were
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quoi boire et n'ya non
non
bâle
jamais dit quoi
le point bas là c'était quoi
[Applaudissements]
ça
[Musique]
alors vite 8 je vais être obligé de
départager les deux équipes je cherche
un petit peu sur mon sens pleure je
crois que j'ai trouvé
vous allez me dire qui est l'interprète
de cette chanson attention c'est moi qui
joue
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
brison reprise de miriam makeba pas ta
ta ta ta ta ta part sylvie vartan bien
entendu donc voilà grâce à ce dernier
point
laurent baffie est à neuf et l'équipe d'
alexandre brasseur à huit vous bravo de
très bien défendu parce que laurent est
coriace
[Applaudissements]
non
d'accord la race et l e par équipe
maintenant on arrive au chacun pour sa
gueule
pourquoi parce que la vie est injuste
laurent et non la pousse à être plus à
vous est décontractée maintenant vous
êtes plus être soumis à la pression de
laurent baffie tout le monde peut
répondre tout le monde peut marquer des
points vous aussi grichka il go bon non
mais sérieux alors on va y aller je
crois un jack il a le bon comme le bon
coup
[Musique]
je crois certes que un petit
la fraîcheur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mc
oh là là bas mais non on ne sait pas un
jeu brasseur
[Applaudissements]
non catherine barma catherine barma qui
est l'autorité suprême de cette émission
me dit c'est ma fille
laurent et généreux un demi point
on est ensemble en audience voilà non
mais vraiment voilà mon mac exactement
attention jaqee tu es prêt attention
joue prochain la guitare continue de ta
mort des six mois jacquot de ma passe de
trois quarts
[Applaudissements]
tu pars
[Musique]
la ouais je vous ai dit pas soufflé vous
savez je suis je suis vraiment
intraitable je crois que vous ne
connaissez mal vraiment je suis
intraitable donc là on en est où là
ouhlala bah fille alexandra fille avait
là vraiment on est dans le vrai donc
tout va se jouer à tout va jouer sur le
méga banques ou mais en même temps il
est super dur le mec un bon coup ça
m'étonnerait qu'ils trouvent blanc j'ai
même pas si quelqu'un va trouver ici
franchement connaît mais c'est dur à
trouver
oui bon on va voir si non c'est chiant
c'est laurent bon on y va de jacky
[Musique]
oui
m
quand il a le ballon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais là
douze mois à l'oreille oui et toi
où aller
voilà
[Applaudissements]
les choses n'ont franchement tu le
savais pas nora - n'aurait pas retrouvé
j'aurais pas trouvé jeunes et la chanson
serait pas trop calme pendant un petit
bout elle est formidable cette chanson
[Musique]
ça c'est le disque de jaqee le byblos la
compil de milos au pinceau blade
testeurs
et j'accueille dj will
d'où des samares
les canards
alors ce qu'il faut dire à nos amis
téléspectateurs c'est que dj will alias
william est non seulement le producteur
de notre ami chris begin mais en plus
vous avez fait vous les connards le
groupe les connards vous avez fait le
les bratisla boys voilà vous êtes mieux
le musicien de michaël youn
diverses et paris
moi ça
oh
marseille qui s'est dit
soit on l'aura
un point bon frédéric beigbeder petite
soeur paule ah oui ça a commencé cette
personne avait garé sa chance et ça fait
un point pour frédéric beigbeder voilà
oui eux à toi là
z'ont rien dit prins calibré
cognac b des jackson five bravo
[Applaudissements]
c'est parti très vite deux points pour
l'équipe de beigbeder un point pour
l'équipe de l'esprit laurent baffie
attention je veux l'interprète dj will
have come again
non ma fille tu greene ron marvin gaye
bravo laurent c'est luis chez loïc qui a
soufflé voilà attention à vous dis oui
[Musique]
vous savez
ah ah
[Musique]
oh
il ya eu tellement le soufflage que le
point n'ira nulle part c'est un petit
peu ridicule
il faut pas soufflé faut pas souffler
donc on reste à 2 2 a vous dit oui à une
police l'en but
c'est bien
les rolling stones voilà bravo enfin
frédéric attention lundi dans deux ou
gens ouais ouais
[Applaudissements]
c'est à pékin pour l'équipe de laurent
baffie the walking dead et iberia a dit
oui
[Musique]
pas de soufflage manière aussi ça brille
ça a été soufflé
ça a été sur fait le plein
si vous souhaitez
ça fait quatre points pour l'équipe de
laurent baffie trois points pour
l'équipe de frédéric beigbeder avoue dj
wiwi dans un bus
[Applaudissements]
quoi
et la victime s'est alors les bitures
l'école et oui ça balance avec le maire
de tulle est reconnaissant
bravo lent voilà je n'ai tout le monde
en parle non non non à toi bitume
peux tu as les cheveux
et voilà c'est un point donc c'est tom
jones est ce ton corps en point je
prends l'équipe de laurent baffie avoue
dj will 6 3
depuis
non
mais greger alors la cdu maintenant si
vraiment je demande la concentration
parce que c'est la fin du par équipes
c'est chacun pour sa gueule
c'est le début depuis le début c'est
comme ça à mellac deux là là si tu veux
c'est vraiment chacun pour sa gueule là
c'est l'ultra libéralisme n'a plus
d'amis les gens demandent pourquoi parce
que la vie est injuste
voilà trois galles for life struggle for
life absolument frigide
attention je veux l'interprète
vous n'avez plus d'amis là d'accord tout
n'a jamais tant n'est jamais mais
attendent encore en moi ses récentes
tensions couvent dit oui
oui
l'euro
métal ce mérite d'abord comme m
bravo
suivant maintenant pas ce meilleur
encore
bien bas nous ça fait déjà deux points
lolo maintenant attention passe à
l'ultra banco attention dj willer à
caraquet
chantée par
diawara
ce mandat
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[ __ ]
maintenant on arrive au dernier et là
c'est très très fort attention très très
difficile
hamon
[Musique]
quand
moi
oui
[Musique]
oui je sais
et oh
quoique on peut dire que lou doillon
emporté sous leur nom mais du souk il a
dit dr dre j'étais méchant j'ai dit dr
dre et si j'accepte que lou emporte la
partie c'est une joie non celle du
maillot
on va partir on passe au blind test
[Applaudissements]
et aux platines j'accueille machine
philippe corti
[Applaudissements]
hu
[Musique]
et si mal
oui est-ce que tu serais venu tout seul
pourquoi alors j'ai même fait beaucoup
mieux thierry oui nous sommes à l'époque
de la mondialisation
d'accord oui l'angleterre ouais
on
monde entier on est diffusée grâce à tv5
dans 87 pays qui étaient en inde aussi
en inde aussi un bon beh oui
qui te dit
oh
non
allez bien
c'est mal
à
oui on est diffusé à la réunion la série
mondiale
à cela vient
[Musique]
corti royal bonsoir mademoiselle joie
bisous voilà un garçon qui ne vient
jamais les mains vides
c'est bien philippe lortie mon format
numérique
en effet plusieurs d'espagne la matière
et je mens
oh
là
[Musique]
c'est après avoir ton carnet d adresses
vous connaissez le principe du blind
test mes amis qui a eu raison des
lunettes marina parce que c'est le
moment pour écouter
oui c'est le moment important écoutant
vous à ce rebond je veux la terre prête
oui attention et on peut donner lundi si
les gens trouvent que c'est un
spécialiste ali c'est un spécialiste a
dit mme richard cocciante banier pas
c'est bien comme exemple parce qu'il n'y
ait pas ça tombe sur quelqu'un souffre
ici le pré va la cua et si quelqu'un ose
souffle la cua ah oui malawi d'achat
très bien parce qu'il est il est belge
et non à la milliers pas faisons jamais
d'erreurs dans le clan pesce jamais
alors à torsion laurent tué près très
près mobile philip wee guy lepage qui
m'a présenté une émission au québec qui
va s'appeler on en parle
faire un nom
simon
cariste attention
on se transcende thomas langmann fonds
se concentre mes enfants monsieur du
buzz attention philippe morceau numéro
un je veux la paix rhdp non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et je vais te dire un blind test de
corps fille c'est ce qu'ont les mecs qui
sont kamikazes quand ils sont fait
sauter pour l'islam
ils ont droit à ça voilà c'est vrai il
ya cinq sont vierges
ouais elles sont bien sûr attiré jean
philippe alors numéro un donc c'est
laurent baffie qui marque le point comme
d'hab' à toi philippe numéro 2 oui
je
andrea bocelli
maire de ses victimes
la partie non
en plus
[Musique]
c'est plus lent
journaux
après j'ai dit c'est quoi
gilles simon
sa passion
alors ça fait j'ai connu le point pour
l'équipe de north ma fille c'est bien ça
ils seront menacées au plan collectif
que marina foïs adéquat pour les
bibliophiles mais c'est pas grave tu
peux te rattraper marina on a dit on au
déjà nous tous nos chanteurs italiens on
est assez accumulé sept autres mais il
est au fond mon cerveau faut qu'ils
reviennent on va revenir
attention philippe que je ne fais plus
rien c'est toto cutugno
av
[Musique]
simon gagné
ah oui
mais
tita à
rien non
c'est effrayant
je crois je crois que c'est albano et
romina paula vaud
c'est la fille de cameron power qui
s'appelle romina power
absolument mais on n'avait pas d'idée
d'y chercher un non seulement on n'a pas
dit les duos non mais c'est connu ça non
oui c'est connu on aurait pu trouver en
face à eux mais on a le point va là
puisque ça a été trouvée la banane et
lui le point va là elle ne l'a pas
souffler à le point bas du côté où ça a
été trouvé ma ba oui oui ça date en
effet bon d'accord c'est déjà pas mal
c'est elle qui décide c'est logique
c'est moi qu'ils aient trouvé la mort
mais attention continue à supporter
[Musique]
m
le tue
partout
chaque fois
sur celle ci
je tiens
[Musique]
serge à qui tu donnes le point à bafilo
à marina
la raison moi aussi je leur ai donné à
marina tu vois c'est marrant attention
philippe cau
galienne tonka côte d'azur
tommy
à
[Musique]
m
bientôt sous cutugno bien c'est comme le
7 à la boule un moment donné il s'est en
ce sens attention philippe
saleh
[Musique]
3 3 c'est très bagarrer ce soir pour qui
le rite a découvert acheter des leurs
philippe il essaye de me demande les
titres et avec thomas
c'est un producteur mais c'est chez moi
que c'est improductif suis sûr que tu
n'as pas de pouls peau ah non mais y en
a 1 2 par le conte est actuaire
comme le sida
[Applaudissements]
t
non
avi
ils m'ont
[Applaudissements]
orlando exige le clip thierry roland qui
va chaque scène d'origine italienne
carré bah oui bah oui valide a redirigé
sens ont été faites un américain alors
baffie on devrait le demander les dates
quand c'est comme ça et surtout trop
s'est passé pas c'est pas impossible
54 oui madame à ce qu'a fait françois
non j'adore ce jeu
[Musique]
j'adore ça là on n'a pas aussi ni la
solitudine que dia on continue philippe
corti madame leconte et fort à la
morricone nino rota la ville et ouais
un bon comptable et violon
d'infimes impérial 6 combats fille enfin
pour l'équipe de baffie parce que c'est
vrai que momo et d un peu quand même
oui série 3 pour l'équipe 2 marina foïs
franck dubosc et notre ami thomas
langmann qui a plus de succès avec 2 0
rachid oui il a un prénom mais il a
retrouvé un monoprix il faut en soi mais
n'a aucune chance d'y arriver là parce
qu'il n'ya pas frédéric françois je peux
te le dire d'emblée
rappelons la règle thiery rappelons la
règle ils peuvent jouer aussi ils
peuvent jouer ils ont droit sans dire
des trucs tu as raison bien simple on me
le dire attention corti
[Musique]
ouais ouais
[Applaudissements]
giedré sciabbarrasi mais bon là sur ce
coup là elles connaissent pas tous
désolés mais enfin on n'a pas les
prénoms là c'est parce qu'il ya on a les
privant de ballons ça sur ses skis à
mélina mélina jeudi comment il fait
clément au centre nadia d'accord merci
je te les ambulanciers après voilà
d'accord bon on continue aujourd'hui
attention numéro
comment bbc
pour
alors grâce à thomas langmann en est à 6
5 6 pour l'équipe de laurent baffie 5
pour l'équipe de marina foïs alors on
continue
attention corti bravo
alors
[Musique]
bien sûr il faut s'arrêter c'est plus un
jeu c'est l'humiliation je suis désolé
on sait pas danser alors là les 1,6
voilà la fin du par équipes on est à 6 6
ce qui veut dire que l'équipe de laurent
l équipe de marina font match nul est un
petit peu que la france contre la
croatie jeudi dernier jeudi dernier un
jeu devient le moyen âge
heureusement qu'on n'enregistre pas le
jeudi parce qu'on aurait raté ont été
baissés
non non heureusement collège en direct
non ça c'est la force et bien
magie du direct faut rien dire sur les
anglais un nom mais les anglais sont
très bien ils ont battu le record des
italiens pour reboucher le champagne on
a perdu à l'issue du par équipes on est
à 6 6 et maintenant on passe au chacun
pour sa gueule
ok j'y vais attention n'y a plus d'amis
a plus d'équipé c'est clair donc
maintenant c'est chacun pour soi
corti à toi pour le bon courage
[Musique]
aujourd'hui
et
[Musique]
là-bas que le mec avait besoin de
cellule à bangui
c'est du bonheur mais
la valeur
il
lui reconnaît que lui et moi du fait que
l'ubs admet pour changer les gens
donnent tajani vibrant chercher ses
ordres à ses fans il vraiment été bannis
d'origine italienne essentielle
je crois que le point légal parce que
pagny pas ses impôts en italie donc je
pense que ça attendez attendez catherine
attendez attendez
obama a dans cette chanson
oui je voudrais que tu passes la
révélation un petit peu plus longtemps
katrina d'or qu'est ce qu'un oui mais
moi je suis fier de me dire ses quatre
fils alors c'est la chef casser la chef
voilà c'est tout
[Musique]
s
ce lot
mon dieu
c'est
j'ai
donc le bon qu aulas a été remporté par
mr achi et voilà il était même pas vrai
au début on passe le super banco c'est
très très très difficile ans je pense
que peut-être agathe godard peut trouver
parce que c'est notre époque chérie
c'est l'époque où on écoutait des trucs
comme ça
blazy même la radio terres noires et
blanches
alors nos abonnés
ouais ouais ouais
m
il a dit il a dit bobby solo in a dit
une fois
[Musique]
plus
alors c'est un spécial rebeu parce que
le premier et le deuxième j'ai me ramène
vraiment la discrimination en facial et
les rebeus qui vient de piquer les bons
coups des français je sais bien alors on
passe au mega brands comme ailleurs ah
c'est hyper dur jusqu'à quand jusqu'au
l'ultra bon comme et façon tu trouveras
pas cherche pas c'est très très dur
corty
[Musique]
mais
sinon
[Musique]
gardena
garmin al madina
en parler
citadine italienne a dit plus claudia
cardinale janis hawk alors elle est très
belle et j'adore je crois pas le mec il
a quand même été il a quand même été au
grand banditisme pendant des années ce
qui a fait la prison colle bien donc
c'est une sophia loren et là je vois que
ça fait quand même deux pour momo 1
momo le turbulent qui marque deux points
momo le boxeur qui marque deux points il
en est maintenant à l'ultra banco la
personne qui trouve ça repart avec
toutes les filles repart et toutes les
filles non franchement je pense que je
vais je vais me défoncer
à 28 ans
bien alors attention tu monde est bien
concentré c'est très très très difficile
moi j'ai du mal
agathe tu dois trouver sa merde elle
dort non je tarde pas les seniors
attention aux fip
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bon
énormes tubes dans les années 60
à
extraits
c'est mon gros du talent
les derniers avertis noyer nova bus qui
sort la lune
je veux le tout bâti non mais
je viens comme jacques martin le
dimanche
jacques borde a été construit voilà là
laurent tu es un dieu vivant
merci dieu existe il est sur le plateau
ce soir cibox merci la navy s'est
inversée
à l'issue dé chacun pour sa gueule
rachid un mot modeuses et les plus
difficiles été emportés par la magie
celle ultra méga banco voilà parce que
le monde est injuste
alors on n'a pas dit ça te le dis
maintenant on dit maintenant pourquoi
alors on pense à toi de le dire parce
que thierry dans l'ambiance
parce que la vie est un juge laurent bal
des médias bongo tout ça que c'est
pourri c'est quand même calibre ce banco
ou franchement c'est chacun pour sa
gueule parce que la vie est injuste
laurent non la moins bien fait que
d'habitude un fait de le faire après ça
nous a bloqué tout d'un coup tu sais pas
ça passe bien c'est un grand avantage
en tout cas c'est un minet thierry henry
s'est aidé par l'émission et il ne reste
plus qu'une après c'est la quille border
sassetti c'est vrai que c'était
l'avant-dernière c'est la pire pour la
dernière c'est la dernière
ouais l'avant dernière c'est la merde et
il voit bien d'ailleurs est pour une non
je trouve
l'avant dernière laurent n'était pas mal
et vous commencez l'année prochaine oui
[Musique]